c'est comme moi vous avez des tonnes de
photos en doublon ça vous prend beaucoup
de place sur iCloud voici comment bien
les supprimer très facilement vous allez
sur votre iPhone dans votre application
photo et dans photos vous allez sur
album vous descendez tout en bas jusqu'à
trouver doublon juste ici vous cliquez
dessus et ça va bien vous trouver des
photos que vous avez en double et votre
iPhone vous proposera de venir les
fusionner ça vous permettra de gagner
beaucoup de place dans le Cloud et
d'éviter d'avoir des photos qui ne
servent globalement à rien et qui
prennent beaucoup de place est-ce que
vous connaissez cette astuce dites le
moi dans les commentaires et puis pour
plus d'infos et plus d'astuces pensez à
vous abonner